-How are you doing?
How is everything going?
-Life is very, very good.
-Hey, you look great.
-Thank you.
I'm glad to be working
in theater in New York.
-Yeah. I think you Zoomed
with us last time,
which was very nice of you
to do.
-Yes.
-Thank you for helping us.
-That was a long time ago now.
-Yeah, well.
-Well, not as long as it feels.
-Yeah, exactly.
But we do appreciate it
'cause we -- Thank you.
We needed guests.
-You stayed in business.
-Yes, we stayed in business,
yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I was asking about your husband
on Instagram because he had
a thing that he was doing,
and I go,
"How long has he been
doing this?"
He's a great artist.
-He is a great artist.
-And did you always know
he was a painter?
-I knew that he was --
He studied art in school.
When I was met him,
he was a graphic designer.
And this is so funny.
We've been together almost
20 years next month it'll be,
and I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very nice.
-You know it's funny.
You understand getting applause
for a length of a relationship
the longer it goes on.
[ Laughter ]
Before it was always like,
it's just a pleasure.
And it is still just a pleasure.
But it's like, yeah,
it's an accomplishment.
-Yeah, that's right. 20 years.
Not too shabby.
-We've been together -- for the
first 18 years, I didn't see him
paint or draw
more than twice I'd say.
And he's kind of had
a renaissance.
He's back in school
studying design.
But, yeah, he's painting dogs.
-Yeah, here's a painting.
-Those are ours, yeah.
-Here's a painting of you.
-That's me with
one of these dogs.
-Are you sleeping here?
-No, I'm actually watching TV.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure I'm watching you,
Jimmy.
-Oh, wow, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-I lay down.
I'm horizontal
when we watch TV normally
and the dog sometimes snoozes
on my chest, yeah.
-Yeah. Your husband -- You said
he's going back at school?
He's at Parsons?
-He's at Parsons for --
[ Woman cheers ]
No relation.
[ Laughter ]
For interior design.
I wish. Always when I came here,
I was like --
"We're not related to anybody?"
"No, nobody."
-Wow, nothing.
-It's sad.
-Yeah, it is sad.
You know what I wanted to ask
you about.
"The Big Bang Theory,"
obviously, everyone loves.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's just as hot as it ever was.
But everyone has been talking
about it lately
because of this new oral history
that just came out
where they interviewed you
for how long?
-I did like 20 hours of
interviews with it.
But honestly it was really the
only way I thought it was worth
doing because I thought this
isn't the kind of thing --
if they're just going to talk
for an hour or two, it's like --
And so, I was like,
"Cool, let's do it."
And it was really interesting
because it was sort of
a decompression of those
12 years that I didn't realize
how helpful that would be
because other people would jog
Memories when she'd come back to
you with other questions.
They're like, "They said."
I'm like, "That's right.
That happened" or whatever.
And it was cool.
-You go, "Oh, I know --"
-Oh, I had my own little box
of what that time was
in its own way.
-Well, you lived it.
-Yeah.
I know where all the bodies
are buried, I like to say.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah.
-But it's pretty -- And do you
see people coming up to you
still that are new fans
or even getting --
-I don't know about new fans,
but I will tell you that
since I've been --
we haven't done it
for three years now or so.
And jobs that I'm working,
people who I guess didn't watch
it all that I'll be working with
suddenly will be like,
"I watched an episode
last night.
You were very good on it."
I said, "Thank you."
But they had never seen it
before.
But I guess they're working with
me like,
"What the hell
did he do on there?"
[ Laughter ]
It's so funny.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's the biggest show ever.
-It's sweet, yeah.
-I also heard you auditioned for
another big show, "The Office."
-I did audition for
"The Off--" Yeah.
I auditioned for the role of
Jim, John Krasinski's role.
And I auditioned for Rainn
Wilson's role.
What was he called? Dwight.
It's really a great example --
-I could see you doing
either one.
-I could see me doing
I also felt like I sort of fell
in between them.
And it was a great example of
the kind of thing
where I don't get it and you see
it air and you see who gets it
and you're like,
"Oh, I would have never --
That's not what I would've done
with it,"
and what they're doing with it
was so powerful and strong
and unique in both of those
roles that it's like,
"That's what should've
happened."
It's the same way -- Like, I
think Rainn would have been
a very good Sheldon, but it
wouldn't have been like me.
-It would've been different.
I don't even think --
He didn't audition.
He was on "The Office," so.
What do I know? He could have
been moonlighting.
[ Laughter ]
-Before we get into your show,
I also want to mention that
you're in a new film called
"Spoiler Alert."
-Yes.
-Without spoiling anything --
[ Laughter ]
-It's already spoiled.
It's a movie based on
the true-life memoir
of TV journalist
Michael Ausiello.
He and his partner, who
eventually became his husband,
lived in New York on a very
similar trajectory of time
to me and my husband
here in New York.
And his husband battled cancer
and eventually passed away.
So this is their journey
through that.
And I think one of the most
interesting things about it is
the way that Michael, as a
person and then the character
in the movie, he dealt with --
his mother passed away
from cancer when he was
a much younger man.
And it really affected, I think,
the way he tackled his husband's
having cancer, like, really
trying to take action
in ways that he couldn't have
as a child.
And, yeah, it was one of
those things that's --
it's a heartbreaking and really
tumultuous journey
but also one of those that opens
your eyes to the life you do
have and the love you can share
in a way that without it
you don't always see as clearly.
You know what I mean?
It's like you can't really
live and love
without experiencing heartbreak.
And I could cry.
I'm not going to.
[ Audience awws ]
[ Laughs ]
Keep it together.
-It's in select theaters
December 2nd.
It opens nationwide
December 16th.
It is beautiful.
And check it out.
Let's talk about
"A Man of No Importance."
Do you love doing off-Broadway
as much as Broadway?
-Yes. This is my second
off-Broadway show.
I did one when I first moved to
New York in 2001.
And it's been a long time,
long enough that --
well, 21 years, that we were
rehearsing in this space.
It's very small,
200 seats or so.
And we're in and out of it.
They're so close that we were
getting close
to audience coming.
I started getting very uptight
about it.
I was like, "Woof, they're going
to be right here."
And then then they arrived
and it's wonderful.
For one thing, it's something
I'm very familiar with
and kind of hadn't
thought about.
That's all the theater I did
growing up.
It was always
in weird little places.
It was never nice, grand
Broadway stages or whatever.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah.
You know, the show itself is
a very intimate show about
a small-town group of people
in Dublin.
And it's partly a man coming to
terms with who he is,
but it's a lot about what it is
to make theater.
And so there's that whole feel
about it.
I keep saying, if you've never
seen anything in a theater,
this is the kind of show
that you would go and see
and be completely addicted.
You would be like,
"I want to do that."
What they're making there,
it's just so --
it's the essence of creativity.
I just love it.
-Isn't that great? I love that.
-Yeah.
-And not only is it awesome,
it's already been extended.
It hasn't even started yet.
-Yes.
We haven't even opened.
-The demand, yeah.
-That was a touch of the Dublin.
-It was. You did a little open.
Yeah, of course.
Before we go, I heard that this
story that when you were a kid,
you used to imitate
Johnny Carson.
-Oh, yes. Coming behind
the drapes, yes.
I was fixated
on a couple of things.
I also wanted a sweater
in the closet of Mr. Rogers.
Didn't want to host his show.
But I didn't want to host
"The Tonight Show,"
but I wanted to come
out of the drapes,
which was probably
a clue for something.
But anyway.
[ Laughter ]
That's two different things.
-Would you like to come
through the curtains?
-Oh, Jimmy! Really?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll do it.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Come here.
You'll hit that mark at the end.
Go to that mark.
I'll meet you there.
-You're not getting a monologue.
That's all I'm saying.
-No, no, no, we're not giving
you a monologue.
We'll cut to there.
I'll introduce you.
And then, can we do that,
like an intro?
-Yes.
-Alright, and I'll just --
I'll be the announcer.
[ Drumroll ]
And here's your host,
Jim Parsons!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How did it feel?
Like the drapes?
-It's really comfortable
actually.
-It feels good, right?
-I'm probably a real egomaniac
because I was like, "That feels
very comfortable."
-Yeah, you're a natural.
Jim Parsons, everyone.
Go check out
"A Man of No Importance."
It's in previews now
at Classic Stage Company.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break, everybody.